[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a suspect in the murder of a teen pleads
guilty nearly 23 years later
the investigation the wrongful
conviction and now justice
we are looking forward as a family to
healing
day two of the second trump impeachment
trial an attorney for one of the capital
riot suspects
responds to the law and crime network do
me a huge favor and
scan that and send it to me i'll be the
first one to shove it right up my
rectum plus the zoom kit mishap at a
court hearing that everyone's talking
about
i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
genetic genealogy helped catch a
suspected killer after the wrong man was
in prison for nearly 20 years
now the idaho man is pleading guilty
gosh what a wonderful bright young woman
that was taken from us
eight-year-old angie dodge was found
raped and murdered in her idaho falls
apartment
in june 1996. i was brought into
them some pictures and identify my mom
was in the adjacent room and i went and
told her i said yeah she's gone long
she's gone police caught their suspect
twenty-year-old christopher tapp
tap's dna wasn't a match but he
confessed and gave police the names of
other suspects
thought to have been involved too their
dna didn't match either
you just want to do whatever it is to go
away
to get yourself out of that little
interrogation to get yourself away from
these people that are supposed to be
protecting you and they're not
a jury convicted tap nonetheless and he
spent the next 20 years in prison
angie's mother carol says she did not
believe tap was her daughter's real
killer
she spent hours upon hours watching all
the interrogations and going over
polygraphs and everything else and she
truly came on board to be my champion of
justice
the most important person in the world
in my opinion
saw that i was innocent the idaho
innocence project took on tap's case
he was released in 2017 and exonerated
in 2019.
investigators teamed up with parabon
nanolabs to use genetic genealogy to
find the real killer
and in this case we were fortunate to
find three genetic
networks is what i call them three
different groups of people
sharing dna with the suspect that have
common ancestors in their trees
and they all converged at one couple so
we knew
that the suspect had to be descended
from that couple
but he didn't appear in the paper
records in the traditional research
he didn't appear in obituaries and so we
originally had it narrowed down to about
six men but it turned out there was a
seventh and that was drying drips
dna from a discarded cigarette to brian
drips
police learned drips lived across the
street from angie at the time she was
murdered
five days after the match they had their
killer in custody
his dna matches the dna sample left at
the scene of the crime
and he has also confessed to the crime
in an interview of both rape and murder
prosecutors reached a deal with drips 20
years in prison in exchange for his
guilty plea
pretty high in cocaine and alcohol
i had a tucker knife with me i just
remember from all the occasions just
laugh
upside my head i didn't
mean to murder her i didn't think i did
but
guess what's happening for the dodge
family this meant a final conclusion
it's been a burden that we've carried
for a long time it's been 25 years
since we lost my aunt and angie
we are looking forward as a family to
healing
and to writing the next chapter of our
lives the plea is contingent on the
judge's acceptance
drips will be formally sentenced on
april 27th
joining us today to break down the case
of angie dodge is defense attorney eklyn
mercy and terry austin
eklund while headlines will of course
focus on drips pleading guilty
and the victim here angie dodge who was
raped and murdered
what about christopher tapp who at the
time was 20 years old and had about 20
years
of his life stolen by investigators
prosecutors and the court
essentially there was two victims
because mr tap
essentially died that day i don't know
if you know but as a criminal defense
attorney
having a pro being prosecuted and
convicted of rape
is like a death sentence in prison so i
do believe that there were two victims
and he should pay for two victims
the simple fact that he had to be free
he was allowed to be free
and no investigators went across the
street and checked the neighbor
heads should roll badges should be
snatched
and people should people should pay
people should pay like
literally across the street how crazy is
that but terry
a part of this also kind of warms my
heart to some degree the man
who committed the crime has found
finally brought to justice
partly because an unlikely hero or angel
i think is a proper word
the victim's mother he tells how she
helped to bring closure in justice
well you know sometimes i think a mother
does know best i mean
she really wanted to find out who killed
her daughter
and she did not think that christopher
tapp even though
he confessed to the crime she didn't
think that he did it she watched all of
the interrogation tapes
i think she probably read from the you
know
actions of the individuals who were
being interviewed
and she kept at it she worked with the
innocence project and
ultimately they did determine that
someone else's dna
was at that scene and they did
ultimately convict
the right person so i think you know
sometimes you have to listen to
the relatives because they do know
better 20 years late but it seems that
justice has been found at least for most
involved in this story thank you both
and now the news out of iota
falls doesn't end there a police officer
is on administrative leave
after apparently shooting and killing a
man in his own backyard
while mistaking him for a fleeing
suspect
police chief bryce johnson said law
enforcement pulled over a vehicle monday
morning
when an occupant fled a deputy relayed
the information to neighboring units
and officers encountered a man with a
gun the chief was vague in his
description of what happened
but said the officer struck the man who
succumbed to his injuries
the man was not the suspect who had fled
but actually the resident of the home
still ahead on law and crime daily the
shocking statement the attorney for the
so-called q anon shaman had to say
to law and crime but first day two of
the second trump impeachment trial we
take you inside the senate chamber for
the latest arguments
stay with us
[Music]
in the second day house impeachment
managers are arguing their case
for the conviction of former president
donald trump in the attack on the
capital
as antoinette levy tells us democrats
say president trump knew there would be
violence on january 6th
six republican senators actually joined
democrats in voting to allow this
proceeding to move forward
stop the steal stop the steal
stop the steal lead impeachment manager
congressman jamie raskin showed tweets
from the president
in which he says trump excused the
violence and said this is what happens
when an election is stolen
raskin repeatedly called the stolen
election claim quote the big lie
trump's tweets and speeches from before
and after the election were displayed
to make the case for conviction the
evidence will show you
that he saw it coming and was not
remotely surprised by the violence
and when the violence inexorably and
inevitably came as predicted
and overran this body in the house of
representatives with chaos
we will show you that he completely
abdicated his duty as commander-in-chief
to stop the violence and protect the
government
and protect our officers and protect our
people
he violated his oath of office to
preserve
protect and defend the constitution
the government and the people of the
united states this wasn't just some
random guy
at the neighborhood bar blowing off
steam
this was our commander-in-chief but
trump's lawyers argue the entire
proceeding is
unconstitutional they say it's about
keeping the former president from
running again
with this trial you will open up new and
bigger wounds across the nation
for a great many americans see this
process for exactly what it is
a chance by a group of partisan
politicians
seeking to eliminate donald trump from
the american political scene
and seeking to disenfranchise 74 million
plus
american voters and those who dare to
share their political beliefs
the trial will continue on thursday but
a conviction is unlikely
many republican senators have already
said they'll vote against conviction
because they don't believe
a former president can be impeached for
law and crime daily i'm angenette levy
thanks angenet an attorney for the
so-called q anon shaman has offered his
client to testify during the impeachment
senior investigative reporter adam
klassfeld asked him to admit that the
conspiracy theory is a lie
on his new podcast objections
your client was also known as q anon
shaman so if you were here today
would he be able to go up in front of
people and say
q anon was a lie there is no elite cabal
of democratic satanists that that is
persecuting donald trump and eating
babies you know would he be able
right now to renounce those beliefs that
he was known and that prosecutors allege
he was a leader of yeah i haven't seen
any prosecutorial allegations that my
client was a leader
of that it was in the government memo
just wanted to you know
do me a huge favor and scan that and
send it to me i'll be the first one to
shove it right up my
rectum and i'll do it on public tv i've
got no
no qualms about that i'll own it can my
client
sit here and renounce
what you're saying you should renounce
yeah
very easily i mean i'm curious if we can
do this on law and crime daily but i
don't think the network will allow us
but
back to discuss the q and on shaman and
trial to remove the impeachment former
president
is defense attorney eckland mercy and
co-host terry austin eckland
i've said some pretty colorful things in
court but this one takes the cake
um what was your reaction to attorney
watkins statements
i just think that the inability of like
the
america's inability to hold rich white
men accountable
is ultimately going to be its downfall
and he has taken it as a joke this
wasn't just a regular crime this
wasn't streaking this was treason
against the united states
government and to take it as a joke and
say like
while your client is standing on while
your client is in custody
for this treason and saying things of
putting things up his rectum he is
taking this as a joke
and it is not so i i just i i have a
problem with it i have a problem with
his attitude
and it should be checked i agree now
terry
the house and pen impeachment managers
played never before seen security
footage
of the insurrection arguing there's a
connection between trump's words
leading to the insurrection how do you
think the arguments are going
i think the house managers have done an
amazing job so far they're talking about
there was the big lie there's the attack
there's the damage that was done after
the fact and they started out with the
video
showing trump's tweets connected to
the actions of the rioters and this
latest video
and this was presented by delegate stacy
plaskett she
in fact is showing what was going on
inside
the house from different angles and you
can actually
feel the tension it's palatable and it's
frightening
and i think it was an excellent way to
demonstrate to all of the senate but
particularly those republicans
who have not yet been convinced of
course arguments are going to continue
in the next coming days we'll make sure
to keep an
update for you as they roll out coming
up on law and crime daily bruce
springsteen arrested for dui who were
only learning about it months later
plus why correction officers in
minnesota are claiming discrimination
over the guarding of ex-cop derek chovin
the lawsuit
next
two men accused of murdering a legendary
san francisco private eye
will remain behind bars without bail
jack palladino died last week after
falling during a struggle with the men
near his home
he had worked with former president bill
clinton harvey weinstein and kevin
costner
attorneys from one of the men charged
lawrence thomas asked that he be
released and placed on home
incarceration with his grandmother
but the judge said that thomas and ty
jones floyno imposed a risk to public
safety
they'll be back in court next week a
former ohio police officer charged with
murdering an unarmed black man
is free on bail adam coy shot andre hill
in columbus last december
a magistrate had set coy's bail at three
million dollars last week
but a judge lured it to one million
dollars and coy posted it
coy has pled not guilty to the charges
his lawyers claimed he believed a set of
keys that hill was holding was a silver
revolver
a new lawsuit filed regarding the george
floyd case terry austin has the
allegations corrections officers are
raising
regarding ex-cop derrick chauvin brian
eight
officers are suing ramsey county saying
they were segregated from the former
minneapolis police officer
because they are people of color derek
tobin was arrested for the death of
george floyd
on may 29 2020. he was taken to the
ramsey county adult detention center
the plaintiffs say the superintendent
did not think they could be trusted
to guard him due to their race they
claim they were discriminated against
when they were told they could no longer
work on the fifth floor
where chauvin was being housed they
allege they experienced humiliation and
distress
so terry essentially this is an
unemployment discrimination case brought
by these eight correction officers
do you think they have a good chance at
winning their case
they have an excellent chance of winning
their case the fact that they were asked
not to work on that floor just because
they were people of color
it is an insult and in many ways
it's an you know demotion because they
were asked
to move to another floor and the
original floor
was really being held for those
prisoners who
were sort of high profile so they can
claim that they were discriminated
against
they can claim that they were insulted
they can claim they're demoted
and also that it was a hostile work
environment so i think they have a very
good chance of winning the suit
yeah and the concept of the belief that
you can't do your job or
fulfill your duties because of the color
of your skin is disgusting and
ridiculous in all ways so of course i
hope that they uh are winning that
argument down the road
thank you terry when we come back a
virtual court hearing gone awry
the zoom filter accidentally left on for
the attorney
not to be confused with a kitten and
what the judge overseeing the case had
to say
you don't want to miss it
jails and prisons have been a known hot
spots for cobin 19 since the start of
the pandemic
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross is digging into where they fall
on priority list with the rollout of the
vaccine
thanks brian this week on brian ross
investigates
the long line for the coveted 19 vaccine
and tough questions
about who should go to the head of the
line should professional athletes
get their shots first what about people
behind bars
including the accused 911 terrorists at
guantanamo
even in prison settings we're not
condemning everybody to death
we're not saying you know because you
were convicted of embezzlement or
uh driving a getaway car you your life
isn't going to be protected
the combination of that plus protect the
community you know one of the biggest
outbreaks brian
in the u.s so far is in rural michigan
and i know why it's theirs because
that's where the state prison is we're
joined by the country's leading medical
ethics expert
dr arthur kaplan watching the mutation
rate on this virus which is going faster
than i thought it was going to
nobody's safe until we tamp it out
everywhere that's this week on brian
ross investigates
brian thanks for update brian
rock legend bruce springsteen was
arrested on suspicion of driving under
the influence in new jersey
tmz first reported on the arrest which
happened in november of 2020.
a spokesperson for the national park
service said springsteen was cooperative
the musician was taken into custody in
the gateway national recreation area
on the new jersey coast he was cited for
dui
reckless driving and consuming alcohol
in a closed area it might be a
rocky road to justice for the next
accused suspect terry austin is here to
tell us about the sticky situation
brian police say a man in new york city
stole eight pints of ice cream but the
getaway didn't go exactly
as planned according to the nypd
officers who responded to a burglary in
progress at a cvs
in east harlem when they arrived the
suspect ran
climbed over a fence and not realizing
how far the drop was
had to cling onto a ledge authorities
say they were able to bring him down
safely and arrest him cartons of
haagen-dazs were reportedly found
in his backpack he faces charges of
petty larceny and criminal possession of
stolen property
what a great story another instance
going viral on the internet an attorney
in texas
couldn't figure out how to turn off the
filter on his camera
during a court hearing on zoom if you
haven't seen it yet
take a look mr ponton i believe you have
a
filter turned on in the video settings
uh you might want to uh we're trying to
can you hear me judge i can hear you i
think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to but
uh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
lawyer rod ponton was appearing for a
civil forfeiture case he was able to
turn the filter off and they returned to
business as usual
judge roy ferguson posted on twitter
after the hearing important zoom tip
if a child used your computer before you
joined a virtual hearing
check the zoom video options to be sure
filters are off this kitten just made a
formal announcement
on a case in the 394th
back meow one last time to talk zoom
mishaps is eckland mercy and terry
austin
eckland great advice by the judge about
checking zoom settings
what did you think when you first saw
this
it was perfect
i mean the best part for me eclin was
i'm not a cat
we can we can go forward
i know you can't terry same
question and do you have any potential
zoom mishaps that you've had over the
last year well brian i've had many
catastrophes on zoom get it catastrophe
listen for all of us parents and
grandparents
keeping up with technology is no easy
task
i really think the judge handled the
situation perfectly
i think at that point just like echelon
is doing you've got to laugh
uh i've known that i've had some of
those as well i know the ongoing joke
for a lot of people
who are on tv or or attorneys who are
doing this is asking the question
are you wearing pants i know i had one
judge ask me that question
i was like judge i'm not quite sure if
that's something you should ask but i'm
definitely going to plead the fifth uh
for our viewers i'm definitely
wearing my suit pants today terry
eckland this is a great way to end the
show
thank you very much uh echo is still
cracking up ecken this is the first time
you saw this
guys thank you for joining us here today
the long crime trial
network hear the long crime daily as we
end on a great note and a bit of a
laughter
thank you for joining us here we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you